town superstar mary wilson passed away
overnight in her home here in las vegas
of course she was a founding member of
the legendary female group the supremes
after it disbanded in 1977 she then
became an activist and a best-selling
author
she was 76 years of age vegas
entertainer
frank moreno had a special connection
with mary wilson jacy fernandez sat down
with him today to talk about their bond
hey frank thank you so much for joining
us today uh i wish that was under better
circumstances
but you we wanted to talk to you because
you had a very special relationship
with mary wilson tell us about it i did
we're actually friends like
25 30 years when i first got to vegas
and we were doing
the diva show of course we had like the
supremes in the show
so mary wilson living in vegas came to
the show this is the first time i met
her
and she was just uh a hoot she got on
stage and she was showing us how to do
the stop in the name of love and all
that stuff
so she was there as the big diva but she
was just very playful and a very
happy person and you know a pillar of
our community we absolutely adored her
what kind of impact did she have on your
career and on your show
well i'm i was a huge supreme fan from
like the age of 16. my sister had given
me a live
the copa album that i played over and
over and over and it had all these big
hit songs on it and
i became you know just probably one of
their biggest fans and then
getting here and becoming a friend of
hers made it even better
um and i would i would see her maybe uh
three times a year i had just had them
over for dinner i had
mary wilson priscilla presley and myself
did like a ladies luncheon it was really
nice
and she's always full of light she was
always like the life of the party and
always willing to
jump in with any craziness i put out
there new year's eve a few years the new
year's day a few years ago i took her
to the old simon's pajama party over at
the palms hotel
she had no problem wearing the pajamas
and she put the rollers in her hair so
a good sport is what i'm trying to say
and just a a great lady
i had talked to her last week she had
called me to say frank she's like what
is your address i sent you a christmas
gift i got it back three times
what am i doing wrong and she just had a
misspelling but as we were talking i
said let's go to lunch one day she goes
all right i just want to wait for coco
to get over with and we'll do that she
goes and i'm going through a few
doctor's appointments and i said
all right one of those she goes i can't
get until the end of february and i was
like you're mary wilson
you know what do you mean you can't get
in so we were talking doctors and i gave
her my concierge doctor i said this guy
could get you in an hour
it's a special service blah blah blah so
i i talked to him about her coming over
and the whole thing set up
yesterday at the blue i just was going
to text and say hey jimmy talk to the
doctor
didn't hear back went to the mail i got
this beautiful gift in the mail from her
but the christmas card came with this
lovely gift
very strange it's called uh time to move
on
very eerie so then later in the day
we were just about to say thank you in a
text and it popped up mary wilson had
passed and my heart stopped it was like
midnight
and it i'm still in shock i gotta say it
but when it hits it's gonna it's gonna
be bad because we were really really
close and
the world's gonna miss a really great
supreme lady